the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
alright everyone has their candles lit
okay so you can start the quiz
yeah it could be left out in force look
you can't believe you know but
I think
alright so times up so if you can just
turn hand all the quizzes down the lanes
to get to me that would be great given
the amount of background and expertise
you have in this area I'm clearly not
going to grade these quizzes with a lot
of cruelty I don't know how to put it
they'll be treated leniently so don't
stress too much about getting it through
the real idea was to call it a quiz so
that you had some motivation to do the
work and then to experience doing work
with a variety of different lighting
situations all of which are pretty
limited in function compared to what
you're used to so we're going to do part
of the lecture in the dark so you should
you can keep your candles and lanterns
and whatever you want on because that's
all we've got for right now I would ask
that you don't use your flash lights too
much because they're really noisy so um
first I just want to talk about what it
was like to use each of the different
lighting sources and like to have to do
work doing all of them using them so
what we started with just candle light
so candle light was quite difficult
there is one is very looking like such a
little very little loss oh so it's
inconvenient oh it's definitely a way to
go without your staple your family or
stick in your head Elaine really close
together and just make sure you speak
loud not sure every weekend here so when
people are sick everyone telling
together yeah Kurt did you have a hand
up it's liquored a lot yeah yeah what
else about the second candle helps yeah
it help diffuse light in I made it a lot
easier to or distributed over yeah
absolutely so the the second candle has
the diffusing aspect as well as the wind
protection both of which add a lot to
their functionality and then next I gave
you guys some aluminum foil how did you
use it and what did you find it useful
so let's go to each group so how did you
guys use those missing we put it under
our CP animals
spray out the light a little bit along
the people
we're all in cash every
it did help and how about you guys then
did you find it helped yeah and then
happy there and and collected it towards
towards your writing area cool and how
it you guys great and you guys actually
started with some tin foil that I guess
you got from lunch nice um yeah so and
then we added the UM the flashlights I
think is that right and some of you guys
use them and some you didn't so for
those who used it what was good about it
like yeah it was very bright very
concentrated oh nice all just the
lifetime wife's manacles
together
so short term shirt sizes but it's a lot
of work so maybe one person would like
doing it quick yeah well you guys like
that Jessica yeah Carter said come also
like when I started with the candles the
person was kind of annoying the second
one got so much better by the time that
we had the lantern that you provided the
flashlight they provided us plus r3
lanterns I was like there's so much
excess like here we don't need yeah so
it's kind of phenomenal how at this
point I imagine most of us are
relatively comfortable in this level of
light whereas if you had walked into the
classroom in this level of light you
would not have been thrilled but
starting with just a candle having all
these light source is actually decent
however can you imagine studying for
your final during finals week using this
amount of light to comfortably study
with this beat would you opt for this
probably not I sure wouldn't I'd want a
whole lot more light to read comfortably
and write comfortably or if you were
sewing or cooking etc so this is both a
surprisingly small amount of light to be
highly functional and yet very clearly
not enough for really optimal for the
people who didn't like the flashlight
what was why did you not just opted not
to use it yeah it was just really harsh
like compared to the
a lot softer and so when he put the
flashlight on it which is this harsh
bright light shows like it could go
everywhere and about one thing we had
some person holding it was just like a
lot better word kind of inconvenient
mmhmm yeah your eyes adjusted to it so
that you like mm-hmm so then you were
beholden to it yeah and how about the
back group we didn't use it I start
using plenty into papers but then my
hand can't wait move it mm-hmm so I had
to squeeze it so I think it'd be useful
for like I don't know like late at night
walking somewhere and shiny in front of
you where you don't have to like focus
it on with an area yeah but for the
purposes of this is really annoying okay
and then your lanterns what did you guys
notice about your lanterns any ones that
you were pleasantly surprised or
Pleasant or unpleasant Lee surprised
about your utility of your Lantern a lot
of people noticed Carter's reflection on
the ceiling
and your original intent was for it to
be straight up yeah I feel like this
lights like around but if you're trying
to read yeah how many of you use your
lanterns in the dark when you built them
cool so oh that's great um definitely
this is a the kind of thing where
ideally you would prototype it in the
dark as you were building it any other
thoughts in the lanterns okay um great
so I want to just run through um any big
questions you guys had on the quiz so
and I am gonna turn on a bit more light
because it's really hard to lecture I
learned this the hard way last year when
I couldn't do anything trying to lecture
so it's gonna gonna get a little more so
um for are there any major questions on
the first page okay and the answers will
be posted on stellar so um yeah you can
see them what did people get on the
first aunt the first estimation seguin
is really helpful I'm sorry I didn't
think this through um so the first
question is have how many average
incandescent light bulbs could an
average adult power by pedaling on a
bike 28 anywhere else
okay so that's about what I got so we're
all in the same realm so a hundred to
two hundred watts pedaling which we
talked about under in an earlier class
and then excuse me and then we have 40
to 100 watt bulb so dividing that out is
anywhere between one and five bulbs is
that vaguely what you guys did great ah
can you see this at all in the back so
you no longer have to maintain your
family bonds so if you want to move
forward so you can see feel free to do
so because I don't know how to maybe I
can try this headlamp try this one first
does that help okay um and now i feel
really awesome fashion wise okay so
second question is that how long will a
solar lantern lasts at night turn to its
maximum settings of four LEDs and so I
heard a lot of questions on this one
like what is a solar Lantern I don't
have any context for this what are you
talking about and one of the muddy cards
that I got last week was why are we
doing all these ridiculous estimations
are you just trying to make me feel
stupid and no I'm really not trying to
make you feel stupid and I totally get
that when you get this estimation
question and it's written just the same
way as a normal problem set problem that
is basically you know like how do you
integrate x squared and you're like I
know how to do x squared I you know the
exact right answer I can do it a hundred
times and I'm giving you this question
with not enough information not enough
details it's a really different feeling
and it can make you feel really insecure
and foolish and stressed out and part of
the reason we're doing this over and
over again in every class is so you get
used to it you get acclimated to it so
that immediate stress response oh my god
I don't know the right answer I'm a
[ __ ] oh my god dissipates and is
replaced by all right well I don't know
off the top of my head let me think
about this what are the context I can
use what are those techniques that we
talked about in the first day of class
that can help me start to approach this
estimation problem so that I can come up
with some sort of answer and that I'm
going to be confident that I'm not going
to get the right answer but I'll
probably get in the right order of
magnitude or in the ballpark and that's
what we're going for here so it's to get
practice with doing this so that you
start to feel more comfortable with it
it's never going to feel the same as
when I asked you how to integrate x
squared because it's a difference
between rote memorization / like truly
understanding calculus and cups
approaching a brand new problem with
very little information and very little
time and knowing how to handle it but
the latter's
really powerful basically anyone can
learn calculus calculus with enough time
but learning estimation takes some
practice at a different level that's
really really valuable long term so no
I'm not trying to make you feel stressed
and the goal is when you see this
problem to spend less time on the what
the heck and more time on the well let's
put it this way no that's not the dead
end let's try this way this way and just
get fluid in those different approaches
so this question the solar lantern lasts
what did you guys come up with how many
hours or days did you come up with yeah
Jessica we already jumped to some of the
assumptions that we kneel them in your
calculations in math class but we forgot
to account for it for example we were
thinking of a three meter squared panel
and here a lantern is not going to be
three meters squared yeah so what I'm
going to say is that we supposed that
we're gonna have a storage device but
that's going to be three meters squared
when our Lantern is only going to be
like the output sort of demand okay um
with the four LEDs and out of that
calculation we got like three thousand
hours okay so given your assumptions
that doesn't sound crazy to me but I bet
other people didn't make the same
assumption on the size of your solar
panel so what were some other
assumptions and answers yeah we used our
solar panel would be a quarter size of
this fall or something
use last then we also assume that only
twenty percent of that solar energy from
the panel would actually convert into
chemical energy for battery storage and
subsequently when we calculate
everything out it was around three hours
okay great so that's a huge difference
but there's a really vividly different
assumptions that mandated that's a
reasonable difference do you remember
how big the panel was last week and then
a quarter of that so we can just compare
let's see it was about a of foot squared
so
the population really didn't cap on the
board with me
did I record that correctly Jessica
that's 3 meter squared is what you
assumed okay and then what about you
guys
so we just use the nominal batteries
mr. said how about like 15 kilojoules
and
charging for LEDs for an hour
cool and what about you haven't talked
to you guys yet what if so he said
insulation on it our Sultana for me R
squared is one simple hours today
Oh
we do their cattle a the wattage of four
bowls for LEDs and he came out to me 375
hours / 75 hours but then take it
serration twenty percent efficiencies
all around he'll go to 75 hours okay so
the three out of the four groups we're
all in the same range and then one group
assumed a much bigger solar panel than
is typical for a solar lantern but isn't
is not untypical for a a lighting system
in a house they're not a typical
necessarily so none of these are out of
control so that's great are there any
other questions on the quiz and I
apologize that I made you hand them back
before I asked you these questions yeah
really strange is there ever a situation
where that's you know practically used
so lighting design and measurements is
really really strange and in my opinion
not being a lighting expert and it is a
very wishy-washy because of our eyes and
how it's we basically don't have a
sensor that can use our eyes and then
there's so many criteria like you have
the source the light at the source and
then you have what it goes through and
then what it reflects off of and where
you're standing and if I'm standing here
versus here that changes my experience
of that lantern really drastically where
you can see me much better if I stand
here but I can't see you at all cuz I'm
completely blinded right so no I do that
intentionally so um that is the reality
of lighting is it's a really wild thing
to measure and understand so a lot of
the metrics that people use are less
precise or comfortable than say beam
bending or other things that as a
mechanical engineer I'm a little more
used to so I'm going to run through
these today and hopefully they'll get
clearer but I can't say that I feel one
hundred percent comfortable and all of
the
and I wouldn't expect that you are going
to do either at the end of the class
today but it's more just give you a
taste of how lighting designers think
about this and if you end up working on
lighting issues having the capability to
know where to go to learn more but yeah
efficacy yeah they're all Lux lumens
candle power at all just as frustrating
the whole set which you guys experience
today I believe any other questions on
the quiz okay so um so now what I want
to do is just show you a bunch of
different light sources so you guys can
leave your candles on but maybe turn off
the flashlights and lanterns so that
unless it gets unless it's really awful
with just the candles so to start with
so this device is called the d light and
it's one of the more well-respected
lantern companies out there it's quite
robust though some of our community
partners who use it it's far from one
hundred percent robust it has a bunch of
different brightnesses that you can use
it has a nice diffuser that makes it
work pretty well you saw how well it
worked here compared to like this
headlamp gets you much more directed
light but it's that's a lot less useful
for most situations so the D Lite is
really pretty great it comes with a
solar panel it comes with I need two
lights now
it comes with a spot so you can charge
your cell phone off of the same battery
that you charge the light on so it's
it's pretty well respected delight makes
another light that's smaller this
cheaper that'll show later on today but
we don't have a version of it
unfortunately other lanterns so this is
made by free play which is a company
that started with radios and they'd also
do a lot of lanterns as well as radios
and it's a hand-cranked one but it's a
little bit nicer than the hand-crank
ones that you got are really a lot nicer
and you can see that the lantern works
relatively well there are some things
that you might want to change at the
break will turn on the lights and you
guys can look through all of these with
full light but what I want to do is just
compare the different light that you get
out this is a lantern that I think is
tie and it has a dimmer and then a sort
of funky diffuser and yeah all of these
I'm just going to show we can sort of
think about the pros and cons if there's
obvious ones i'll show you what uh I
think I don't know what it's called it's
made by Jeep GEEP this is the the bogo
light which is getting distributed a lot
around here i'm not sure where they get
their money but like everyone i know who
has one got it for free at some
conference superb so they're distributed
a lot it has a big solar panel on the
side and then it has different levels of
LED lighting that you can use it
automatically turns off if it's in the
Sun some of these do that so if it's too
light it won't let you use it to run
down the batteries it has a clip so you
can hang it on something on your
backpack or wherever another one that
IKEA makes is kind of neat
a desk lamp and there's a similar desk
lamp that the that delight makes the
thing that's kind of interesting about
this is that the solar panel pops out so
you can leave your light inside and then
you can take your solar panel and put it
outside so that it captures the sunlight
you need to power it the drawback is if
you lose that centerpiece you're stuck
um so there's a pro and con there um
this is a light that takes like a little
LED simple can you guys see this at all
when I do things like this okay takes a
little LED just hand light and then it
has an extender for it so that it
diffuses the light and makes it useful
in other situations where you just don't
just want the task light it's a little
hard to use a lot of lanterns are based
on the classic like kerosene lantern
that looks sort of like this this one is
a modified design that so bright hmmm
that has a fluorescent light instead of
using kerosene but it's still very
similar design what else do we have we
have a whole bunch I'm going to start
getting just to the ones that are
interesting this is one that should
remind you of your solar Lantern kind of
or not cylinder of a DIY Lantern because
it's very much DIY and the connection is
a little flaky but you can see it has a
built-in switch sorry for the glare for
some of you maybe i'll point it this way
it uses a CD is the reflector which
works really well comparatively and then
just wood for holding the batteries and
a found switch most people in developing
countries if they upgrade from candles
upgrade to kerosene so I'm very quickly
going to show you kerosene
so here's a kerosene lantern and what do
you notice about it so it's totally
smoky it's smelly kerosene is pretty
dangerous so I would be hard to imagine
wanting this in your house if you had to
for a variety of safety reasons and
certainly carrying around be dangerous
and it has the same flickering issues
that a candle has obviously so I'm going
to blow it out now so we don't smoke
yourself out yeah we're like outside man
turns to keep the mosquitoes yeah so
Matt is looking like luau torches yeah
it's the same kerosene so that's one of
the things that um kerosene offers is
mosquito repelling and that's one of the
things to think about for all of these
lights is that traditional lights do
offer some benefits that people like
like mosquito repelling like heating in
some areas so then and just going back
to grid light bulbs for a minute we have
a set up here so watch your eyes this is
a 40 watt incandescent light bulb which
is comically low in normal housing but
and yet when we're used to this low
light is ridiculously painful so then
you can add a reflector which makes it a
little less miserable to use but if you
notice just the color of the light and
then compare it to this incandescent or
this fluorescent light this isn't the
fluorescent light that's the same color
is these fresh and bulbs they've
actually done a lot to improve
fluorescent light color temperature to
make it more pleasing to the eye whereas
LED lights are still quite comparatively
blue this one has a nice diffuser so
it's less painful but you can see how
drastically different the color of light
is and light color really tends to
impact people's mood and perception of
the life and how much they like the
lighting so while LEDs have a lot of
potential the color temperature issue is
strong the light I was using earlier the
headlamp was really annoying because
like it's great for task lighting oh
this is a better one actually but it's
very eye blind you really fast right so
they invented this diffuser which I
think up the dork factor an amazing
amount but and there's a reason like I
found this at rei unlike more than it
was like 75 percent off because I think
no one's buying this because while the
idea of a dispute or makes a lot of
sense if it doesn't look good you're in
trouble and this really has a lot to be
desired in terms of how good it looks on
and that's true everywhere that what
what a device looks likes matters okay
so um so yeah so at the break we can
look through all of these you can look
through all of these different lanterns
we have okay so I'm going to turn on the
projector now about the kinkajou
projector which was actually originally
invented here at MIT in two double-a
nine
so that's the kinkajou which as I
mentioned is an offshoot and you can
notice already how much brighter this
classroom is just from the little
projector is sort of shocking from the
art traductor which is amazingly bright
now so the kinky projector again came
out of my teeth suitable 9 class and
then through it went through a lot of
iterations to where it is now so i
wanted to show some of those iterations
so this was the initial prototype that
came out of two double 09 I made up
something there and you can see it being
tested here and then it went through two
iterations to where it currently is
today you might have heard them mention
that they used fisher-price optics which
sounds really funny right um but toy
companies do an amazing job of getting
costs down really low and then producing
in high volume and so one of the things
that can be really handy as if you know
their toy is going to stay in production
for a long time you can harvest those
parts and that something do you love
health has been starting to do if you
know that something's going to be
readily available for the foreseeable
future why not use those parts it's a
lot cheaper than manufacturing yourself
or even buying it yourself sometimes so
the reason I wanted to show this is just
because I think a lot of one of the
reason I want to show this is because a
lot of times we sort of think about
prototypes is like oh we have a
prototype and then we have production
and instead like into double a 9 they
probably did three or four prototypes to
get to this point and then this just
throws three prototypes and there's
actually many more that they had to get
through to get to a version that they
could actually produce in relative
quantities and this is still in the
order of magnitude of hundreds of
projectors not thousands or tens of
thousands or millions one aspect the
Canadian projector that also came up
into double a nine a second year was how
do you power the kinkajou and so
students worked on this device which is
basically a rowing machine to power the
device which worked really well Harvard
students came up with a treadle powered
device and then what they're using
currently
is a battery pack that connects to a
solar panel these devices can you think
why a solar panel might be chosen over
these devices way more affordable
absolutely minimal work yea noise yep
time super yeah so these the price of
these two sets is relatively similar but
it's a whole lot easier for kinkajou to
ship solar panels than it is to ship
stuff like this and then there are some
gender issues which were addressed
between this and this in terms of who's
allowed to use the power but still it's
no one wants to be sitting riding a bike
or doing doing a rowing machine while
you're in the classroom if instead you
could have a solar panel oh and so while
human power is great we talked about
that a lot last time there's still
opportunity for improvement ok so this
lecture is adapted from suzanne site
linger who was in the smart cities part
of the Media Lab and she got her PhD
last year i'm not sure where she is now
but she taught this lecture last year so
that's where this is coming from so just
to give a little bit of context one and
a half billion people don't have access
to electricity about a third of the
population in this situation lived in
India so that's why a lot of the
projects are going to be talking about
our base in India also India has a
relatively high growth that's providing
wealth to a lot of people and then still
a very second set of people who are
getting very little benefit and so the
contrast make means there's some
resources and some opportunity there to
to do work there and the international
energy agency doesn't predict this is
going to change very quickly so most
people are relying on other fuels
kerosene dung wood diesel candles
battery-powered flashlights for lighting
and all of those
have some real drawbacks you saw the
drawbacks of kerosene and candles at
least some of them you can imagine the
drawback of battery-powered flashlights
if nothing else is just the cost of this
batteries wood is really dirty dung is
as dirty as it gets in terms of indoor
air pollution issues and it also
interestingly like just as wood is bad
for the environment dung is also bad for
the environment because it's a really
great fertilizer and regions where they
use a lot of dung to do other things the
quality of the soil goes down
dramatically and then diesel and
surprisingly is rather dirty and
dangerous similar to kerosene one other
issue that's really interesting is how
much you pay if you if you have modern
lighting as opposed to kerosene it gets
very expensive very fast so this is just
a set of the range of how expensive
different lighting is compared to how
how light it is and this slide is really
hard to parse and I added color to it to
make it a little easier to parse but
basically what it's showing is how much
the the y-intercept is how much the cut
the initial cost is and then the slope
is what is the continuing cost so
ideally you want to be like right down
there right so free to start and as low
as possible a very low slope so that the
cost of ownership isn't going up so for
example a solar 5 watt compact
fluorescent lantern is really expensive
and it just keeps going up in costs
because even though you think its solar
it's free it tends to break a lot and so
the cost keeps going up so it's really
expensive candles start out free but
they keep going up one thing I found
really interesting was a simple kerosene
lamp has a pretty nice low slope
compared to most of these technologies
and then the hurricane kerosene lamp
goes way up and I was
wondering what's the difference does
anyone have a thought so a simple
kerosene lamp is like this one and then
a hurricane kerosene lamp it sort of
like the classic lantern that you
imagine sort of like this but with
kerosene in it instead of any thoughts
as to what the difference that
discrepancy is yeah so that's one
possibility yeah uh I don't think it
burns brighter yeah isn't it so then
they instead it has to replace yeah yeah
so both Lanterns have wicks right that's
how you get the kerosene lantern to work
and a simple kerosene lamp can use
really really simple wick and a
hurricane lamp requires more expensive
wick and so that's the cost driver and
it's sort of phenomenal because you
think oh I so much prefer a hurricane
lamp because it's going to enclose it
it's going to make it a little less
smoky it's going to make the candles
flicker a little less but if you have to
use this special wick it's going to cost
so much more very quickly and then a
grid-connected 60-watt incandescent lamp
is pretty great a compact fluorescent as
we're all familiar with costs a little
more initially but then your slope
improves and hopefully you make back
your purchase pretty quickly so i found
this graph to be really interesting when
you start to have questions about what
the differences are i put up the
assumptions for table that table but
generally up to thirty percent of it
yeah sit on yeah
chocolate slow best friends kerosene are
you talking about like like on what
basis are you estimating the cost of
electricity like is that the cost in the
US or the constant so you can see I'm
here I mean you can't read it right now
because it's too small but you can see
the assumption so they assumed that grid
electricity in rural areas is about ten
cents per kilowatt hour you know of
course you can't see that it's
impossible I can barely read it so I'm
not I didn't put this up so that you
could read it but that's you have it on
your slide so that you can look through
it later if you have questions like that
yeah and I didn't expect you to be able
to read that whole slide in all three
seconds or whatever um so yeah so but I
put that up there so when you have these
questions in comparison it's easy to
figure out what the assumptions were and
these assumptions are a few years old so
some of the drawbacks of solar and LED
lighting are getting better but they're
still it's I'd still say worse we're in
relatively the same picture with some
improvement so financial costs are a big
issue with lighting so people can spend
up to thirty percent of their income on
light and in this country we three
percent is the best estimate I could
come up with but it's really really high
because when we collect data on what we
spend in the US you don't really break
it out like you don't break out
utilities and how much of your electric
bill is light versus how much is your
electric stove versus your electric
water heater etc so three percent is
really high so people can be spending up
to ten times more than we're used to
spending which has a huge burden of
course environmental costs are severe
from the proper disposal of batteries to
wood deforestation and then one that we
don't always think about is light
pollution so that's less of an issue in
super rural areas but it is affecting
everywhere more and more and certainly
in this country light pollution has a
really big impact it's great to have
light from a safety perspective but then
from other perspectives light pollution
can be really problematic in terms of
pleasure at night and being able to
enjoy the night sky being able to have a
darkened room at night
social costs of not having light so
everything becomes difficult at night is
I think became clear just now so people
who don't have light go to bed really
early compared to people who do have
light there's some agricultural work and
other type of work that need to happen
at night either because they have peak
periods where like if you don't fish and
these you know this one month you want
to fish as much as humanly possible and
if you can't fish at night you lose a
ton of money to things like people
collecting rose petals that has has to
be done at night because once the Sun
comes up the flowers start to wilt it
means you just have less time in your
day because you only have the time of
the Sun it disrupts education if you
can't do any night school you can
imagine how challenging it is do surgery
with no light and get medical care in no
light and so if you have any problems
when the Sun isn't up medically that can
be really dangerous then of course just
security issues it's well understood
that having lighting helps with security
in terms of health costs breathing
kerosene fumes and other smoke and
indoor places is awful the including the
particulate method emissions there's
just a danger of fire started when you
have a fire lit that's why I actually
included the candle holders for the
first candle is it gets those candles
get really hot and I didn't want anyone
to get burned and then just I strain
makes makes your day is harder so I
think now is a good time to take a break
and then after the break we'll talk
about the all those different
measurements of Lux and lumens and all
that good stuff oh it's as I mentioned
earlier it's a dynamic process it's
contingent on a lot of variables like
what are the requirements of the task
you can imagine that reading is a very
different task than cooking in terms of
what lighting requirements you need but
both you need significant amounts of
light to do well mood and atmosphere are
important
appearance the aesthetics the visual
comfort related health safety well-being
the social communication aspect of
lighting the different people's point of
view costs and environmental concern so
there's a lot to consider and some
specifics so brightness is both the
intensity and the amount of light and
you can sort of see the extremes of
staring at the Sun thankfully through a
camera lens and how bright that is
versus the glows and this is not coming
out that well so I'm going to turn down
the lights a little bit does that look a
little better or the same I can't it
looks a little better than my act um so
the glow and then glare is an issue that
you guys all experienced I think today
of getting shined at by one of my lights
or one of your lights in your face and
you really can't see a thing except for
the light that's blinding your eyes so i
won't clary blind you right now contrast
is another thing to consider so
something with very positive contrast
where the object is brighter than the
background as opposed to the reverse
where all you can see is the silhouette
because the background is brighter than
the foreground and again like obviously
if there's no contrast you can't see
anything and then one thing to think
about is illusions associated with
contrast so you've probably seen this
before but this color gray and this
color gray are the same color and it's
just the black versus the white that
changes your perception of grey you can
click here in the slides to go see a
cool animation where they actually like
move the gray off and on so you can
literally watch the contrast happen and
the perceived change in the gray color
happen right before your eyes it's kind
of cool that's called whites illusion
you guys all experience candles in terms
of contrast issues and you'll notice
that
obviously I'm not going to lie could
light a candle right now so why don't I
when it was pitch dark the candle was
really really evident and useful and now
it's kind of bright but it's not as
shocking or as useful as it was and then
another thing to notice in this picture
and because it's a painting it's a whole
lot easier to get the contrast than if
it were a camera which is why it's a
nice picture to use is that this candle
light works pretty well for lighting her
face but it's probably pretty terrible
for lighting her way in terms of not
tripping on anything and so candles have
some aspects that they work really well
on and others not so much the color
temperature issue but we talked about so
I think this will be less painful now
still a little painful but not as bad so
the extremes and you can see like the
candle color temperature versus
incandescent versus fluorescent versus
like improved fluorescent versus a more
traditional fluorescent versus the LED
it's a huge range and even if we had no
lighting and just for using the Sun the
difference between sunlight and shade is
pretty significant so we're used to some
range so expecting that there's some
perfect color that will that is the one
we're shooting for is not necessary but
candles certainly are on the far end of
the spectrum and LEDs aren't shown here
but are on the opposite end and pretty
unpleasant yeah so that's Kelvin so it's
like a heat temperature
measuring all of these you can read up
on all the different ways that people
measure this sort of thing and the
controversy over the different
measurements again because it's so
subjective it's really hard to get a
really analytical measurement that
captures all aspects of light
performance so speaking of that just
going through the terms so the lumen and
I find this diagram to be really helpful
is the light that's being emitted and
then the luminous intensity or Candela
is the lumens per angle and then
illuminance is oarlocks is the lumens
per square meter and then luminance is
the what the luminous intensity that
reaches the eye is everyone totally
clear on that so so yeah all the little
words are somewhat similar and we're
just talking about different ways of
looking at it and because you can only
ever see the light using your eye unless
you have a light meter which will be
getting but we don't have right now it's
sort of difficult to even conceive of
exactly what these mean apart from just
hypothetically and then of course
brightness is subjective and not
something that's really easy to measure
you guys look confused do you look
confused
so so like I understand Luminas like an
energy like the amount of light that's
emitted
but not as a flux
I think luminous flux would be more we
can
so I understand what you're saying that
the wave flux is used in this set of
definitions is contrary to the way
you're used to seeing flux and I cannot
take credit for these definitions so I
can't help you resolve that conflict
only to agree with you that it is
confusing you got it I'm sorry this is a
under luminous intensity cannella or per
Radian mr. radiant um so it's the stair
Radian is again a strange measure of an
angle I'm not going to ask you to derive
or calculate luminous intensity oh just
so that you're familiar with these
existence yeah yeah
strange like the measure of solid okay
it's just it's like if you have a circle
to every radio it's just nothing about
just fear ok so the same ideas that are
you nice i'm just reading for sooner ok
ok and so here are a bunch of these
quantities with symbols and SI units
some of which help and some of which add
to the confusion like the difference
between light incident on a surface vs
light emitted from a surface it all gets
complicated and so basically the
takeaway from this is that if you want
to actually compare two lights and say
this one is superior to that one it's a
lot of work and a subjective even with
these hypothetically some of these
objective measures it's challenging
because of the nature of our eyes just
sort of like odor is challenging to
measure too so when you're using a basic
light meter you're measuring illuminance
which again going back here is just
measuring the light emitted onto a
surface so you can compare when you
using a light meter some of the things
you want to do or compare vertical
surfaces and horizontal surfaces looking
at where the light source is usually
it's very rare in a room of the earnest
location there's only one light source
when we all had just four candles there
were four light sources if only one
family had the candle would have been
one light source but normally there's a
whole lot there's my computer there's
the projector there's the overhead
lights there'd be light coming in from
the windows of the doors if I hadn't
covered them up so you have to consider
all of those and then the straight light
sources and then whether you're
measuring at eye level and where exactly
is I love what are you assuming an
average woman or an average man or
something else and then also at the task
surface as opposed to the I surface all
of those are important
um just to give you a sense of order of
magnitude of how bright and how on
bright yeah do you have a question Eric
did you have a question or was your hand
just move it sorry all right um so we
can range a whole lot of order of
magnitudes from a bright star at night
which is still pretty dim but if you've
ever been in the middle of nowhere in
the middle of the night it's amazing how
bright stars can be on a moon within a
night with no moon it's surprisingly
bright once your eyes adapt sue moon how
strong a moon is to a living room
hallway toilet versus living room this
really depends on how well your toilet
in your living room are lit compared to
each other there's a lot of variation
here so this is general metrics but
there's a lot of variation of core of
course and then sunrise our son right
sunset is going to be much brighter than
your living room and then going all the
way to full daylight and then direct
sunlight is incredibly bright and
piercing so if you think about like
sitting on a beach with no clouds just
how bright that is it's shockingly
bright yeah
versa
what do you think
does anyone have a hypothesis for why an
overcast day has more luck than sunrise
or sunset I guess there's a fuser worse
all right since I just not to work son
but more of
we're use not done right it's very
indirect and then the angle of the Sun
is much lower on the horizon so the
percentage of the Sun that's actually
the rays that are actually providing
light to you is significantly lower and
there's a lot more diffusion yeah so
there's recommendations for task
lighting again in luck so we can use the
light meter and you can see that they're
typically measured in horizontal as well
as vertical illuminance and that a
kitchen reading desk work all require a
certain level much much higher than if
you're just doing general tasks and you
saw that today that we could get away
with a ridiculously low level of Lux in
this room and function when we just had
candles and maybe a little bit more but
if you wanted to be really reading or
studying comfortably you wanted
tremendous amount more locks
vertical units will be like from the top
to the bottom right not like going down
vertically so they're talking about
measuring it on a horizontal surface and
a vertical surface and then also outside
we have to worry about a lot of
different ranges and you can see that
you care a whole lot more about lighting
a monument if you care about everyone
seeing the monument than you do say in
your garden you can give you a whole lot
dimmer and people can still walk around
and again when I was talking about all
the different areas that you have to
worry about you have Claire you this is
the point of interest you have light
pollution that's going to affect your
measurements you have some reflective
surfaces all of these different areas
are things to consider this is one way
of looking at it with a physical diagram
and this is another one that sort of
runs through the different ways that you
can measure these different light issues
ok so I've gone through all these
different basics on how to measure light
and these basic criteria there's a whole
lot more content that we could go
through that I'm not an expert in and I
don't think it's crucial but if you do
get into this area it's deep and
interesting so again we talked about
just the quality of the light of a
hurricane lamp say if you lit by
kerosene versus an LED light the
experience is very very different both
in terms of the experience of how bright
it is the color of the light the
cleanliness the cost all of these things
are quite distinct and this graph or
this chart really sort of tries to
document those differences so the
brightness is pretty severely different
that a fuel based light is much much
less bright typically than electrical
light the quality is much poor which you
guys saw and then the reliability well
either one can be unreliable right
and you kind of have to define when you
mean by reliability what's more
important to you relying on the grid is
great until the grid becomes so
unreliable that you stop relying on it
which has happened to my neighbors for
example when M star was really
misbehaving a few years ago so it's it's
an issue everywhere that things that
seem reliable aren't always and then you
start choosing different type of
reliability so now I want to go through
some examples of lighting and lighting
tasks so learning is obviously a huge
area where light provides a huge benefit
to people if you can be studying and
we're going to class at night that frees
up a tremendous number of hours in the
day that you can work and similarly
working so i mentioned people plucking
flowers people farming silk from silk
worms and people cooking it's all of
these things are really benefited from
being able to work at night these two
examples are from cellco which we'll
talk about later and a few slides
markets and vendors so if you can sell
at night as well as the day that opens
up a lot of potential profit and
potential customers for you and then we
talked a little bit about medical care
and the benefit from all the way you
know from having baby babies to
emergency surgery we're having light at
night is really crucial and then just
walking and being safe at night anywhere
from driving to wandering it's really
handy to have light unsurprisingly and
then if you think about how much time
you spend at night socializing and how a
much harder that would be if there was
no light to do so and how much less time
you'd have for interactions with your
peers and with your friends and family
at night so lights like the street light
provide you know provides an opportunity
for people to start all of a sudden
meeting and socializing and or
together so some examples of light so I
mentioned the D Lite and I think this
light has been upgraded a little bit and
is now called the d-10 or s10 maybe the
s10 but basically it's made by the same
company d light that makes this light
but they this light is about sixty
dollars maybe 40 in some places and this
light they're selling it around 10 and
so it's a whole lot more affordable it
doesn't offer the cell phone charging in
similar aspects but they've also worked
a lot about making sure that it offers a
really good quality light some of the
limitations of this light for example
we're really clear and just how glaring
it was and it's nice to have light at
all but glaring light isn't ideal and so
they've done a lot with diffusion to
make sure that this light is pleasant to
use and this is a nice sort of side by
side picture of using a kerosene lantern
versus using a d-light you can see the
the difference this is much much
brighter and probably a whole lot more
pleasurable to read by as long as it's
not too glaring and they also had two
settings so that you can save your
batteries if you need to Grameen Shakti
you may have heard of Grameen Bank and
Grameen Shakti is a related program
where they've been providing a solar
electrification primarily for lighting
too many many homes and so they're one
sort of classic example of focusing on
PV systems to provide lighting cellco
which I'm going to show a video on about
in a couple of minutes is another
example where as I mentioned so they
were using kerosene lamps to feed
silkworms which they needed to do at
night and kerosene lamps as you can
imagine are dangerous and not only are
they smelly and toxic to people but
they're killing off silkworms because
they're toxic to silkworms too and so
stuck cellco was able to develop a solar
lanterns
that became affordable through some
complicated financing methods which is
cellco does a combination of Technology
and financing that allows people to
access solar lighting that they couldn't
otherwise access and it has had a lot of
benefits similarly solar-powered
headlamps the story on this project is
that initially midwives came to cellco
saying we really need solar powered
lanterns like headlamps not just
lanterns because if you can imagine when
you're delivering a baby you need task
lighting run center and if you have a
lantern behind you your body is blocking
what you need to see and so it becomes
very inefficient and you don't want a
kerosene lamp right up and close that's
just dangerous and so cellco came up
with a head lamp but unfortunately
midwives don't have enough clients to
pay for the headlamp so then cellco
looked at well who else needs these
headlamps and they came up with a
headlamp sharing method so that people
flour Parker pluckers construction
workers rubber tappers and midwives
could all share the headlamp so that
everyone could benefit so that requires
not only some special financing but also
some special community arrangements so
that everyone is able to share these
headlamps successfully but if when
they're successful it helps tremendously
for a lot of different people so now I
want to talk about cellco or show you a
video about cellco the founder of sure
be Sean day and I think the thing that
isn't going to come out in the video
enough is what he really learned very
quickly but had to do a lot of work to
figure out how to address is that he had
people regularly telling him that 300
rupees a month is expensive but 10
rupees a day is fine and you can do the
math really quickly and see that those
are the same right that 30 times 10 is
300 so why do you think one would say
that
like the site exactly it seems like more
money because like 300 is 10 but also
because like I mean I think it's hard to
it's easier to like budget page today
it's hard to budget like an entire month
so like it's probably easier to like you
know save ten rupees every day as
opposed to trying to like save 300 from
one provision onshore a lot of variables
yeah so the budging editing cycle is
actually the huge thing that people
using kerosene lanterns would sell
during the day and if they made enough
to buy kerosene at night they would and
if they didn't they wouldn't and so that
gave them a lot of flexibility for their
budget whereas if you spend three
hundred dollar or 300 rupees and then
you have a bad month you're out and
there's no ability to optimize that on a
short cycle
one yeah so yeah somebody feels it or
its logs or drums up
yeah so saving is risky and it's also
hard if that if you've never been
brought up to be budgeting which is
something that if you live in poverty is
not something that you're really doing
on a month to month or year to year
basis but are living day-to-day shifting
to that mindset is very difficult and it
does add an element of risk if you're
saving money you have to save it
somewhere that has to be secure which is
a big assumption any other thoughts so
and this is her esha's quote but having
talked to him my understanding is that
three hundred rupees a month is
expensive but twenty rupees a day is
fine so people are really generally
spending much more to live day to day
than they are if they could live once a
month but living months a month is a
barrier so high that it's completely
insurmountable for people at a certain
level of poverty and below so I'm gonna
switch again Street markets are a
crucial part of Indian commerce street
vendors sell everything from vegetables
to incense to clothing to handicrafts
much of the action takes place in the
hours after dusk normally the vendors
depend on kerosene lamps to light their
wares cellco thought that the street
vendors would be better served by solar
lighting but the vendors were in no
position to purchase PV panels and
batteries for solar lighting so cellco
redesigned the value chain and created a
new class of vendor the solar lighting
entrepreneur with financing arranged by
cellco solar light entrepreneurs
purchase large arrays of solar panels
that can be placed on a roof or even a
vacant lot every morning the solar
entrepreneurs connect a series of
batteries to their PV panels the 12-volt
batteries are the size and heft of car
batteries the entrepreneurs have a set
list of clients on the market some get
just batteries others get both battery
and lights the entrepreneur we visited
dada hyatt has over 50 clients at
four-thirty the solar entrepreneur
disconnects the battery's loads is
motorized rickshaw and drives his wares
to the market a few kilometres away
he then delivers the solar-powered
batteries to his clients
for the vendors the solar lights proved
to be a good deal anything's worth of
light costs about fifteen percent less
than kerosene wood for the same time
period the lights have other advantages
over kerosene as well they cast a wider
arc of light don't smell and do not pose
a fire hazard for solar entrepreneurs
such as dahiya the lights are also a
good deal after making his loan payment
and paying off other expenses hyatt has
enough left over to live on moreover he
also has the possibility of further
expanding his business ok so I think one
of the things that's amazing about
cellco is that the idea of someone
basically renting a light or access to
light every day kind of seems obvious
and simple now in twenty-twenty
hindsight but at the time is quite
radical and if you you can kind of
imagine why like it's sort of impossible
for me to imagine every day stopping by
the market and borrow you know renting a
light to use tonight ok and tomorrow
bring you back and repeating that's so
contrary to our societal norm that it's
hard to wrap your head around and so
this was a really different approach
that would turn out to be very very
successful and is a great example of an
approach and why are we talking about
this in energy class well any solution
has the technology piece but it also has
the business feasts and while we're
certainly not emphasizing the business
piece and if you wander there's other
deal of classes where you can focus on
that you can't design in a vacuum
assuming that if the technology is good
enough they will come regardless of the
financing this is you can't assume
there's a good enough financing model
that's good enough if the technology
isn't and if you read watch a bunch of
her ishan days talking he'll he gets to
that that you need both in order to be
successful so that wraps up the lighting
lecture that I have are there any
questions on lighting so I know you guys
are really interested
in the community partners will be
working with and what exactly will be
will be doing so I wanted to go through
first what students did last year I mean
do you mind bringing those three
products over so one team worked with
blue energy in blue field which is on
the Atlantic coast where they have a lot
of batteries that these deep cycle
batteries that need to be recharged
regularly and the batteries they need to
be recharged with distilled water and if
you don't use distilled water you
shorten the life of the batteries by a
really significant amount and these are
very expensive batteries that make up a
big percentage of the system and people
are living in islands and coastal areas
where the only way to get to buy
distilled water is to travel by boat for
a few hours which is expensive and when
there's any sort of weather is
impossible and so people will naturally
just use regular water rather than
distilled water and by regular water I
generally mean well water or worst case
ocean water which kills the batteries
really quickly but there's a temptation
just I no need to fill the battery so
let me do it with the water i have here
if I can't get the stillwater still
water also isn't free if you're buying
it and so what they developed were two
different approaches to a distiller use
at two different cost prices or price
levels so one using acrylic panels and
one just using clear plastic sheeting
and then you just put it over a water
source and the water evaporates in the
Sun then and the when it evaporates all
the stuff that's not just pure water is
left in the pan of the down here and
everything that is floating rolling down
the sides is distilled water and then it
collects this isn't a good option for
drinking water both because distilled
water tastes awful and isn't as good for
you as water that has some minerals in
it and also because it's a pretty slow
process but if you only need a small
amount of water per month for a battery
this works really well and can be made
pretty much out of locally available
materials
is pretty simple and so that was one
project the students worked on what do
they do when they went to blue energy we
did a charcoal demonstration for people
so that they could learn how to make
charcoal out of coconut husks because
that was what was locally available that
involved going to a coastal area that is
one of those areas where you can't get
too except for boat they called Kaka
bila so we spent some time there just
learning what the energy situation
situation was like helping repair a wind
turbine and identifying other projects
in Bluefields that we could work on and
this is the project that ended up
getting worked on all of these projects
are going to be relatively small
compared to say a two double and nine
projects and that's the reason for that
is twofold one is that this class we
pretty much work on projects for half
the semesters opposed to the whole
semester and the other reason is that I
really want these projects to get to
completion so a project that we can
actually hand off to a community partner
at the end of the semester and say here
run with it and they can without it
falling apart and something like oh it
kind of doesn't work and a lot of
projects just naturally in academia get
to the it just works well enough for the
presentation and that's it and I want a
project that will work well enough to
hand off which is a different level and
so that's why we do relatively smaller
projects but we get to deeper level of
design on them so the next one is a bag
sealer so this is working oh and blue
energy is likely a group we won't be
able to work with this year but this
group worked with Auto Phoenix which is
a group we likely will be able to work
with this year and also Phoenix one of
their projects was to make a bag sealer
for orange juice so in the one of the
regions that also Phoenix works with
they have a micro hydro system and they
actually are under utilizing that
electricity that they're provided the
electricity doesn't work year-round
because the water isn't there year-round
but in the rainy season they have sort
of a plethora of electricity and they
also have a plethora of oranges um and
the orange growing season is relatively
short so you have all these oranges
and you can you can sell them for very
little the marketplace because all the
oranges come to season at the same time
and so they're trying to figure out how
do we say the oranges to save some money
and so they looked into preserving the
juice and then selling the juice and
being able to sell that for longer than
you would be able to sell the oranges
and so the key piece that was missing
was how do we seal the bags and so bag
sealing technology exists but having a
simple one that connects to a micro
hydro electric system that's easy for
them to repair and build in the field
with something that didn't exist and so
that's what this group of students
worked on and when they were at also
Phoenix again they did charcoal
demonstrations as well as identifying
the different projects that they could
work on in this this year's class we're
doing it slightly differently that we're
going to pre talk about the projects and
you're going to work on them a little
bit before you go that year they were
really just doing project identification
this prototype is already been delivered
to group of Phoenix which is another one
of the groups are going to be working
with so I can't show it um apart from
the picture but this group makes solar
panels from cells that are reject cells
that don't meet the specs for evergreen
solar so Everdene donates the cells to
group of Phoenix and they cut them up
and make solar panels with them and
cutting a solar cell is really really
difficult and in the field or in the lab
you would do it with a laser but a laser
is well beyond the capability of group
of Phoenix which is off the grid pretty
much and so this group developed a
fixture for a dremel to allow a more
repeatable process for cutting the cells
so that the loss rate went from like
eighty percent to fifty percent so a big
improvement even the fifty percent is a
painful loss rate eighty percent is much
more painful and then the last group
worked with one group organization
called cadre which again we probably
won't work with again and also for
group of Phoenix which we are working
with again for a stove and a stove
design so I we introduced the charcoal
idea to group of Phoenix women their
group of Phoenix's our community that
has a very strong organization of women
almost entirely and those women are
really interested in alternative energy
and so they they build their own solar
cookers the solar cookers are really
expensive and so that's a problematic
model from a financial long-term
standpoint but from a community building
social standpoint it's a really
interesting very successful model and so
we're we're interested in working on
them to figure out what are some other
opportunities they can look into then
might be more sustainable long-term and
one of them is charcoal and they're
really interested in charcoal but they
all use Adobe stoves meant for wood
which aren't appropriate for charcoal
and so I am the students working on this
project came up the idea to develop a
stove in a stove so a charcoal stove
that would pop into your Adobe stove
wouldn't interrupt your cooking but
would allow you to use charcoal very
easily and the students came up with the
idea of making sure the stove is
something that could be built by the
women at group of Phoenix so what they
came up with was a stove that can be
made from a single piece of sheet metal
with just a couple of cuts and then a
bunch of bending and so they figured out
the stove idea over spring break and
then in the summer one of the students
went back and introduced the stove
taught a workshop and how to make that
and got somewhat tested it with some
women to see how it worked which is a
pretty cool project and so that's the
stove right here so those are the four
projects that came out last year and so
this year we fly in to Managua which is
the capital city but we spend almost no
time there the group of Phoenix is in
oak at all we may work in keno Tyga and
also Phoenix is based generally in the
Baco region
so also Phoenix is a small Nicaraguan
based NGO focused on rural sustainable
development and they do a lot in the
energy realm they're actually a group
that was spun out of group of Phoenix so
that's why the name sound so similar
it's in a very very rural area which
means you have to hike in there's no way
to even get a good pickup in and so it's
pretty rustic conditions pit latrines
bucket showers if there's enough water
and sleeping on hammocks and one of
their big projects is they have a feed
shopper and they want to be able to
electrify it because right now it's
human powered and it's a really really
manually intensive system to use it and
then they also have interest in bio
digesters maybe continuing work on the
bag sealing project and they're
currently having a meeting this week i
believe to talk about what other
projects they'd be interested in that's
one second is grupo Phoenix which is in
ocotal and this is a group that has a
university base in Nicaragua at the
technical university in Nicaragua and
has some connections back to D lab as
well as other universities so it's a
little bit more westernized just a tough
but it is very integrated into the
community with that women's cooperative
that I mentioned and so they're really
focused on trying to empower the women
to create better energy solutions for
themselves and preserve their national
resources so this group has comparative
wealth and that some of the houses have
TVs things like that so some of our
students last year were surprised by how
wealthy we were working with the people
we're working with one of the reasons
that these women are comparatively
wealthy is that this program has been
going on for 20 years and some of the
work has allowed them to gain a little
bit of wealth but the neat thing about
them is that they serve as sort of
figure heads for the whole region and so
success that they have make gets other
people really interested and so it's a
really neat program to work with
some of the projects they are interested
in but again pit latrines bucket showers
is sort of the standard but you do get a
bed as opposed to a hammock so it's a
little bit more refined is refining
their solar cooker ideally refining it
significantly to make it much more
affordable easy to manufacture
aesthetically pleasing etc etc more
functional there's actually a group of
Cornell students working on aspects of
that as well so it would be interesting
it'll be interesting this figure out how
we intersect but they're going to be at
a group of Phoenix at the same time so
that it would be an easy way to overlap
they're also really interested in
charcoal making in the stove making and
so working with them on those aspects
both from developing their skills and
making charcoal as well as business plan
development and then they're really
interested in figuring out a good way to
make cell phone chargers because that's
a huge solar cell phone chargers because
that's a huge need in the area where
almost everyone has cell phones and very
few people have electricity so charging
the cell phones is really difficult
other possibilities that we're looking
into right now are collaborating with
d-lab health because deal of Health has
a lot of other projects and they also go
to Nicaragua and so it seems natural
that we could collaborate and they often
have energy needs for their solutions
and so it seems like a natural overlap
so I'm talking to them but Jose who
teaches the class just got back from
Nicaragua yesterday so I haven't been
able to talk to him about that yet and
then visited he know Tyga this summer
which is another region and they're
really interested in making charcoal
from these invasive lilies in their lake
and so that's another possibility but I
don't have strong enough contacts to be
able to be sure that that's going to
happen but it is a possibility that I'm
working on are there any questions about
all of these
okay so by friday i will have a survey
online so that you can list your project
preferences and i know these are
relatively vague but that's the nature
of this work and then i'll need you to
put complete that by monday even if
you're not going on the trip I need your
preference because you're going to be
working on the project apart from going
on the trip and then we'll have the
teams formed by the 23rd and then from
there you'll be assigned a project
mentor and you guys will be working in
your teams to work on developing initial
information information gathering
initial prototypes that you can bring to
Nicaragua to help you have a more
informed conversations with your
community partners and make a better end
product in the end or the other aspect
of work that may be happening in
Nicaragua in addition to gathering
information about your project so
getting feedback on your initial
prototypes your initial approaches is
trying to transfer some of our
technologies to the community partners
are working with so for example group of
Phoenix is really interested in doing
some more charcoal burns so we'll do
that a group of Phoenix and you'll be
trained and charcoal burns right before
we go because we try to push that as
late as possible so that we're not doing
it in the snow um I haven't had a chance
to talk to also Phoenix if they want to
do charcoal burns again if there's some
other technology they want the primary
work will be project fleshing out the
projects and getting project feedback
but there may also be some transfer but
not a ton so does that answer everyone's
questions about all of this because
there were a lot on the muddy cards so I
just want to make sure that's clear
okay cool so now I want to go through
the muddy court cards again which I try
to do every week one person asked was
the average daily energy consumption for
Americans which hopefully you're into it
at this point I brought I showed it on
the first week slides it's relatively
easy to look up but the average American
uses about fourteen thousand kilowatt
hours per year of electricity so that
that's not all energy that we consume
obviously but it gives you a baseline
someone was confused about how mega
joules and kilowatt hours are related so
they're both units of energy and it's
3.6 megajoules is one kilowatt hour and
generally power and energy intuition is
muddy so okay can you guys remind me
energy is equivalent can you can you do
a quick definition of the difference
between energy or power or a metaphor or
however you want to define it but how
are you guys keeping it in your mind
ords money for everyone so yeah yeah so
so excuse me I was like velocity
distance yeah and energy is proportional
to distance so Power has you're
considering time and energy you're just
considering the net and yeah if this is
feeling uncomfortable I would practice
it for the first quiz they get that into
your head and come talk to uh meet or
myself if you want to spend some more
time on it yeah so I'll talk about that
in a minute so confused about the
dissipation of energy in the grid and
the having the wrong length of wire so
basically what we talked about last week
was that the longer the wire the more
the bigger resistor you have and the
bigger resistor you have the more heat
loss you have and the more heat loss you
have less energy transfer you have
because more that is going into heat and
less of it is getting to your end source
and your end use so that was the the
basic gist of last time was that you're
never going to be able to transfer
electricity perfectly from one system to
another because there's always going to
be efficiency losses but the farther
distance you have to travel the more
loss you're going to have and so you
need to either minimize the distance or
minimize the resistance associated with
a wire in order to have a successful
transfer I hope that clarifies it a
little bit if not again come talk to us
still a little confused about batteries
again talk to us because that's too
general a question for me to know what
to answer but hopefully we can sort it
out together and then
estimations of my daily energy
consumption would be easier with given
values of wattage for common appliances
yep sorry so the whole idea for this was
to practice the estimation and then use
those estimates to do your first pass at
your daily daily energy consumption but
then have the time on the homework to
refine those estimates with actual real
numbers but the intent is to practice
this estimation so that's why I didn't
just give them to you and then one last
question was the source differences
between we talked about the load
differences but we didn't talk about the
sources and so we were sort of doing a
black box source and so we'll talk about
solar power and more detail and wind
power and more detail coming up but yeah
right now we're sort of thinking about
it as a black box so that's why it's
muddy because I haven't made it less
money yet okay are there any questions
about all of that so one thing I wanted
to mention just to finish up on the cue
drum because I didn't want to talk about
it too much until you guys did all your
readings and stuff is some of the
criticisms of the Q drum and I also show
the hippo roller just so you see a
different version but a similar approach
so what do you think some of the
criticisms of the Q drawn might be leaks
yeah so once it starts leaking it's a
pretty crummy technology to have yeah
yeah so on terrain like is shown by that
boy it's pretty manageable but stairs
were sort of an extreme version of
terrain but you can imagine and super
steep were areas it's not so fun to use
so terrain was one concern the longevity
the leaking what else
yeah so that's a really big issue on a
cue drum because you have your valve
right at the edge of the drum and so
your valve is rolling in the mud
basically and so every time you open and
close the wall the drum you're getting
dirt into the drum which makes it
dirtier I someone in this classroom told
me that the hippo roller now has a UV
light inside it to try to address that
issue they also have their valve a whole
lot higher up in terms of water
cleanliness issues so that is one of the
limitations of the Q drum is just how
dirty your water has the potential to
get and it's pretty near impossible to
clean out a Q drum successfully because
of the way it's constructed any other
thoughts yeah yeah so a whole lot less
versatile and expensive and prevalent
right like you can find a five-gallon
bucket everywhere pretty much or the
equivalent a Q drum you can almost find
nowhere there's no and if you think
about shipping a five-gallon bucket they
stack into each other so you can fit a
whole lot more or five gallon buckets in
a shipping container then you can queue
drums and that makes the queue Jerome a
whole lot more extensive because
shipping costs get very high very
quickly any other thoughts of concerns
one of the biggest ones when this
technology came out was they use
pictures like this one to advertise it
and people were horrified because kids
were carrying water which is a really
interesting thing to think about right
because kids are already carrying water
so it's not actually a very sensible
concern from the approach of what is
really happening but from a where are
you getting your money from concern it's
huge because if you alienate all your
donors by showing them an improved
reality but they aren't aware of the
real reality and you don't educate them
well you destroy your donor
and if you're going off of donations
which you have to do in a queue drum
because it's so expensive that's a real
problem and so I think that's one of the
most interesting aspects of the queue
drum for me is one you know it seems so
great kids are dragging water instead of
carrying it what a huge improvement but
if your donors are assuming now you're
this is allowing children to carry water
who used to be in school then all of a
sudden no one will support you so it's a
really interesting aspect of this type
of work and then just to check in on
where we are today we did lighting and
commune your partner reduction the lab
will be Friday next week will be solar
thermal and PV and the quiz in the flip
order that's what we just decided and
then yeah this is this is where we're at
you